Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P. We
have switched live phone calls from a sort
of normal phone line to using discord.
I think that the calls are much better, both
in terms of audio quality and in terms of
substance.
But this caller doesn't like it.
He's almost like begging me for mercy to stop
the calls altogether.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 4: Oh, my God.
No more just more calls right now.
I would show if you want to hear from people
around the world, it's horrific.
Speaker 1: Oh, thank you.
I appreciate the compliment.
Yeah.
Listen, I mean, we've gone through this before.
Most people like the calls, the people that
don't absolutely hate them.
We've packaged them in the second half of
the Friday show.
The rest of the entire week of shows is not
live calls.
And we are we are looking at, you know, different
mechanisms maybe for screening or different
things.
I get it.
I get that it's not for everybody.
But we actually do get the calls that are
good, I think are really good.
And the audio quality has improved, underscored
the substance has improved on this court.
So we're going to keep it going for now.
But it's very easy to skip it if you don't
like it.
OK, on the bonus show today, we will talk
about Democrats blocking a resolution to censure
Maxine Waters over her comments regarding
George Floyd, Derek Shoven verdict protests.
I think her comments were misguided.
We will talk, though, about the absurdity
of the censure resolution, given what people
in the Republican Party have said.
A U.S. senators are looking to ban private
ownership of lions and tigers.
This is actually part of a bigger story, which
I will talk about on the bonus show as well.
And we are going to talk about the completely
abortive launch of my pillow CEO Michael Dell's
social media platform.
It was a disastrous and humiliating fiasco,
which I love it.
I'm not going to lie.
I am really enjoying the disaster of the my
pillow social media platform, launch all of
those stories and more.
And I will be joined by producer Pat on today's
bonus show.
You can get the bonus show as a member by
signing up at Join Pakman Dotcom.
I believe to this day that the normal membership
pricing is very, very reasonable, but I am
always glad to offer you a discount.
You can use the coupon code immoral to anyone.
Yes, immoral.
The discount is so low it's almost immoral.
Immoral to one.
All one word, all lower case to get a big
discount off of membership.
And then you will get instant access to the
bonus show.
And I will see you then for tomorrow
Unidentified: if you're not a member.